You may by now be familiar with the notion
of evaluating a function
with a particular value,
so for example,
if this table is our function definition,
if someone were to say,
"Well, what is f of -9?"
you could say, okay, if we input -9
into our function,
if x is -9, this table tell us
that f of x is going to be equal to 5.
You might already have experience
with doing composite functions,
where you say, f of f of -9 plus 1.
So this is interesting,
it seems very daunting,
but you say, well we know
what f of -9 is, this is going to be 5,
so it's going to be f of 5 plus 1.
So this is going to be equal to f of 6,
and if we look at our table,
f of 6 is equal to -7.
So all of that is review so far,
but what I want to now do is
start evaluating the inverse of functions.
This function f is invertable,
because it's a one-to-one mapping
between the xs and the f of xs.
No two xs map to the same f of x,
so this is an invertable function.
With that in mind,
let's see if we can evaluate
something like f inverse of 8.
What is that going to be?
I encourage you to pause the video
and try to think about it.
So f of x, just as a reminder
of what functions do,
f of x is going to map from this domain,
from a value in its domain
to a corresponding value in the range.
So this is what f does,
this is domain...
and this right over here is the range.
Now f inverse, if you pass it,
the value and the range,
it'll map it back
to the corresponding value
in the domain.
But how do we think about it like this?
Well, f inverse of 8,
this is whatever maps to 8,
so if this was 8, we'd have to say,
well, what mapped to 8?
We see here f of 9 is 8,
so f inverse of 8
is going to be equal to 9.
If it makes it easier,
we could construct a table,
where I could say x and f inverse of x,
and what I'd do is swap
these two columns.
f of x goes from -9 to 5,
f inverse of x goes from 5 to -9.
All I did was swap these two.
Now we're mapping from this to that.
So f inverse of x is going to map
from 7 to -7.
Notice, instead of mapping
from this thing to that thing,
we're now going to map
from that thing to this thing.
So f inverse is going to map
from 13 to 5.
It's going to map from -7 to 6.
It's going to map from 8 to 9,
and it's going to map from 12 to 11.
Looks like I got all of them, yep.
So all I did was swap these columns.
The f inverse maps from this column
to that column.
So I just swapped them out.
Now it becomes a little clearer.
You see it right here,
f inverse of 8,
if you input 8 into f inverse,
you get 9.
Now we can use that
to start doing fancier things.
We can evaluate something like
f of f inverse of 7.
What is this going to be?
Let's first evaluate f inverse of 7.
f inverse of 7 maps from 7 to -7.
So this is going to be f
of this stuff in here,
f inverse of 7, you see,
is -7.
And then to evaluate the function,
f of -7 is going to be 7.
And that makes complete sense.
We mapped from f inverse of 7
to -7
and evaluating the function of that,
went back to 7.
So let's do one more of these
just to really feel comfortable
with mapping back-and-forth
between these two sets,
between applying the function
and the inverse of the function.
Let's evaluate f inverse
of f inverse of 13.
f inverse of 13.
What is that going to be?
I encourage you to pause the video
and try to figure it out.
What's f inverse of 13?
That's, looking at this table right here,
f inverse goes from 13 to 5.
You see it over here, f went from 5 to 13,
so f inverse is going to go from 13 to 5.
So, f inverse of 13 is going to be 5,
so this is the same thing
as f inverse of 5.
And f inverse of 5? -9.
So this is going to be equal to -9.
Once again, f inverse goes
from 5 to -9.
So at first when you start doing
these functions and inverse of functions
it looks a little confusing,
hey, I'm going back and forth,
but you just have to remember
a function maps from one set of numbers
to another set of numbers.
The inverse of that function
goes the other way.
If the function goes from 9 to 8,
the inverse is going to go from 8 to 9.
So one way to think about it is,
you just switch these columns.
Hopefully, that clarifies
more things than it confuses.